[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's was ich weiß noch gar nicht
was es gibt denn ich habe heute eine
ganz besonderen gast sie war schon
einmal da und ich freue mich sehr dass
heute wieder da ist matt mosaik alex
[Applaus]
jetzt weist irgendwie wohnen jetzt
kannst du jederzeit vorbeikommen ja und
wer sie auch ja wir erinnern uns an
unsere letzte bugs session diese
[Gelächter]
kreativ
ich finde das ja auch super angestellt
war soll es nach gebracht habt ihr die
torte letztes mal nach gebacken ja
ja wir haben im podcast zusammen
aufgenommen der war auch super
unterhaltsam ich glaub da hätten also
viel angeschrieben sie hätten uns noch
stundenlang zu gehen also ich habe auch
ganz viele nachrichten bekommen dass die
leute sich danach sehen das ist noch mal
passiert ja deswegen machen wir das auch
heute definitiv also wenn uns heute
vorgenommen dass wir es packen und du
sagte selber von dir kochen ist total
deins banken jetzt vielleicht nicht so
da arbeiten wir dran
wir und ich habe mir gedacht das was
heute auch recht spontan machen denn
mein vorratsschrank ist immer gefüllt
mit allem wo ich habe auch glaube ich
alles immer daran dass er in jeder zeit
als button könnten ich habe mir gedacht
hast du schon mal cupcakes gemacht und
wirklich so schöne cupcakes auch
aufgespritzt
nein nein also ich hab ich habe schon
top picks muffins zugleich hätte ja also
muffins das quasi so ohne creme und
cupcake ist damit klarer machen auf
jeden fall cupcakes und ich will so
richtig welche die so richtig prallt
sind und saftig und großen ja da habe
ich lust drauf okay dann würde ich
nämlich sagen gehen wir an meinem wachs
schrank und das suchst dir einfach
zutaten aus die duh möchte seinen an
erstelle ich ein rezept dazu frei
schnauze reinach schnaufend machen wir
aber das rezept gibt es da natürlich
ganz genau zum nachbacken für euch wenn
alles klappt aber ich denke schon das
ist ganz gut klappt und was sich die
nicolet auch schon immer mal gewünscht
hat aber da müssen wir uns nächstes mal
ein bisschen mehr zeit dafür nehmen ach
so ja ja
das ist das gleiche thema wie beim
letzten eine pippi langstrumpf torte
dieses mal wieder nicht gibt ja
sollen wir eine pippi langstrumpf torte
zusammen machen
nicole hat meinte wir müssen uns dann
auch verkleiden ich bin fast übel mit
ich bringe die kostüme mit 18 4 2
wir können nicht mit rein ja bei dir
brauchen wir einen richtig dicken draht
den weg ist schön nach oben nur so
einmal und so hat man kann auch eine
kordel machen beide ende
dann etwas isst sie proben und nicht nur
in kostümen mit und dann packen wir eine
richtig geile pippilotta torte machen
ihr könnt sie auch mal ein bisschen
unter druck setzen dass es wirklich mal
passiert weil ich bettle ja schon mein
leben ja so wie damals bei der reporter
dort habe ich auch ein bisschen länger
gebraucht weil hast mich so unter druck
gesetzt gefühlt habe und genau in dem
gleichen stil in dem schwierigkeitsgrad
in dem aufwand machen wenn pippi
langstrumpf hortkinder fährt der affe
die frau das haus muss halt eine woche
bei mir einziehen kein problem also
kommt lasst uns zum bug schrank jetzt
untersucht die sachen aus und gern
ich habe angst
okay hier ist der bug schrank dich auch
ja
ich bin froh dass auf jeden fall über
alle und sticker drauf ist der vor
einigen zum beispiel hier back trends
reich wirst du sonst finde dass das
maximum break
was ist mit den grundzutaten mail und so
kannst du auch genau das brauche ich
auch aber das ist weg ich genau dass es
weg alles gut du kannst dich jetzt in
also du kannst arag zu überlegen nur
wonach der kaffee schmecken sollen also
wir machen den teig an sich eine creme
und nur links also auf jeden fall
brauchen wir hier meine heißgeliebten
sollte karadzic ist sind das ist ja
genau mein ding
finde ich richtig gut dann brauchen die
schoko drops
schokolade und karamell es genau mainz
vanille extrakt ohne läuft ja nichts und
kontraste finde ich auch immer ganz zu
suchen nehmen wir jetzt mal marzipan
lebe ich ja auch so sehr kann ich ja so
es welche sorte ach
so ja stimmen
das ist wie bei riegel hier
was ist denn wenn die dorn sanddorn
selten da nehme ich sie die dort
täglich mecki dann finde ich das immer
ganz lecker er schließlich mag süß und
salzig 1 gerne
und das
war ja das war's das ist ja zum topping
später oder so noch irgendwie
wissen so kekse mit schokoladen gesagt
ja ich wusste jetzt nicht was das ist
weil ich hier ist leider kein sticker
druck
deswegen ist das gerät die abteilung weg
okay das reicht ja das ist können noch
weniger ist mehr das sieht man bei mir
ja auch das ist mein motto dann hole ich
noch gut im korridor fudge guckt euch
auch noch probleme hat es auch gut
wachstum noch die grundzutaten ja die
sind noch da
ok also hier sind jetzt erstmal die
grundzutaten und ich habe jetzt gedacht
machen wir doch direkt die doppelte
menge dass wenn wir top picks haben zum
dekorieren dekorieren und zum spaß haben
und wenn du diese grundzutaten zu hause
hast ich glaube dir hast du
wahrscheinlich immer oder eier zucker
salz und sie weiter und wenn man die hat
dann kann man quasi immer muffins oder
cupcakes zaubern und dann gibt man eben
durch diese speziellen zutaten noch den
geschmack dazu ich sage ich mal kurz die
zutaten und wie gesagt doppelte menge
also für 24 an grundzutaten haben jetzt
hier für etwas wandel extrakt jeweils
300 gramm sonnenblumenöl und buttermilch
400 come back melodie verwendet normales
mail plus backpulver plus natron etwas
salz und etwa 300 gramm zucker und jetzt
überlegen wir uns was möchten wir vor
ein haben also welche sachen in die
creme und welche sachen in den teig
direkt ich hätte gesagt zum beispiel
diese chris burns ist so kekse mit
schokoladenüberzug die stromburg & rau
genau
deko okay die creme also tonka passt da
kann man vielleicht auch in ihr stopp
ich gesagt habe habe ich bin ja
vorgemacht
also ich mache was du möchtest ich würde
die hälfte der muffins komplett aus
schokolade machen so richtig viel
schokolade und dann sollten ein partner
marzipan führung bekommen das ist ja
kein thema für dich und
das machen wir einfach überall rein oder
ok wenn sie das gut hier kann man ja was
machen und dann gerecht die
ganz schwer karamell ich sind da machen
wir die rein würde ich sagen und die
hier oben drauf als dekor anstatt die
perle ok und sie hier auch dies wäre mit
schokolade kommen die schon gut aber ich
bin grad nicht mehr sicher bewegt als
ich finde wenn die schokolade mit
erdnüssen und karamell combin ist das
passt ja sowieso 1 niklas wir eine panik
aus ja können wir ein paar zu machen und
ein paar zur business marzipan ja super
schweizers max und mia sommer dann aber
auch noch karte zunehmend und ist ein
klares ja wohl ich nur kurz ja
ja und dann mit ihr das einfach so
ineinander und dann ab in die türmchen
und teufeln danzig jetzt wird für mich
jetzt mehr herausforderungen das rezept
dann für euch anzulegen das ist macht
das trio wieder da kann ja auch mal
nicht schreiben ja oder einfach mal wie
in kochsendungen früher ja einfach so
ein zettel in die hand nehmen einfach
damit dass kröten rückumschlag wochen
lang ohne geschenke bringt das rezept hm
nicolet schreibt euch dann doch wieder
das genug machen
ok dann lasst mich kurz zutaten abwägen
und dann starten wir direkt erstmal mit
dem teil machen wir die muffins auch in
einer papiertüte genau ja muss man ja
ist schon gut so haben die einfach so
wenn du magst genau gebe ich dir schon
mal die backform sondern die papier
förmchen auge
die hier auf jeden fall bestreiten japan
nach mir her
[Musik]
ich bin pink elmar duffner ja für so
schokoladige sachen
grünen
nehmen
das war eigentlich auch aber das ist
auch so hübschen ja die sind für so xxl
muffins für diese diese
mcdonald's noch warum haben wir keine
mcdonald's markt können wir auch machen
dann haben wir jetzt mal wenn wir heute
haben wir einiges zu tun aber die
zuschauer aber ich bin ja auch was
geboten bekommen naja
dann wie wäre es wenn wir dann diese
snickers mafia als neckars mal völlig
diese fette kumpel oben drauf haben ja
und die anderen marzipan dinge daran
sehr gut
hatte ich nicht neulich nach einer
herausforderung gefragt hier doch
einfach nicht ertragen können ja
einfach gar nicht die community einfach
die kollidiert herausforderungen ja
genau gut dann machen wir hier noch kaum
rein und dann
da kannst du schon mal die eine backform
da nämlich mit dem papier förmchen und
die andere mit denen anderer schützen
gebrauch dieser war schön schwer
[Musik]
also tatsächlich reicht dann die
doppelte menge
erstmal nur für die xxl dinge und nur
immer noch mal die einfache menge aber
das passt ja alles dann haben jetzt hier
alle zutaten und werden jetzt praktisch
ergänzt für die sneakers xxl muffins die
schoko drops debug festen erdnüsse kakao
und solltet kernel patches in der cookie
dough version und falls ihr diese
cupcakes oder muffins macht nach meinem
grundrezept dann ist auch ganz wichtig
zu wissen falls ihr das back mir nämlich
verwendet da ist schon backmittel drin
und auf meinem blog und in der app steht
nämlich drin backpulver und natron und
es gab es schon oft menschen die den
fehler gemacht haben die praktisches
backen verwenden und trotzdem noch
natron zufügen müsst ihr aber nicht das
heißt wenn ihr das bak gehabt da
wirklich kein bug trieb mittelmeer
zufügen da ist nämlich alles schon drin
und dann exakt durch die sollten mal die
koki dorfes das sind praktisch so
karamellbonbons und die gibt es eben
zwei geschmacksrichtungen soll ja alles
kaufen genau dies schon offen leider die
vor kurzem eröffnet wurde
dann darfst du jetzt zuerst einmal alle
flüssigen zutaten hier eingeben
von nass zu trocken hier
einmal die ja besonders auf dann hier
ein guter schuss ja man muss ja was dran
warum scheitert das backen bei dir bei
mir leuchtet ihr helfen
also man muss dazu sagen dass mir das
nicht so viel spaß macht und nicht mit
meinem kochen auch ein bisschen
flexibler ich habe beim kochen auch beim
kochen kann ich alles noch gefühl machen
und ich habe mir so ein gutes gefühl für
lebensmittel und beim backen muss mich
ja schon an regeln halten schon von haus
aus die
beide beim backen muss man schon so die
zutaten und alles
schon gefolgen
warum machen wir das eigentlich heute
nicht in deiner rührmaschine von 3000
stück und ich dachte mir nicht leicht
ist die maschine
wieder frau man tatsächlich keine also
man kann eine benutzen aber ich finde es
immer schnell kurz per hand besser so
als haben war dass die krise salz immer
ganz wichtig genau
und die trockenen zutaten salzen und ja
ich assoziiere langsam
warum arbeitet man immer
ist es medizin herausgefallen
patrick wird lesen die katze
ich guck mal ganz kurz
es geht ihm gut vielleicht möchte er
später den xxl muffin probieren die
leute wissen wir gar nicht wie der juni
ist der gesamte haus und hof schreinern
da ist schon bekannt ist ein richtiger
star hier ist das so ja er macht mit
monate monats fünf minuten und dann
betteln die sich immer es war eine lange
zeit mal weg ist aber wieder da und er
möchte auch wieder kochen und backen ich
glaube wenn ich denen gesagt hätte du
kommst hier vorbei
peter buck damit
kummer sieht es gut aus
acht cacau nahm war auch direkt mit rein
denn gewollt weil sich die klubs das
kriegen wir gleich weg was ist mein tipp
wenn es mal klemmt dann würde ich
tatsächlich kurz einem handrührgerät
machen wenn ihr ein plumpes mail habt
dann gern auch sieben vorher aber das
bak male das glück bin ich also das wird
wirklich das kurz früheren und dann wird
es schön geschmeidig seit dem
handrührgerät geben ja natürlich derweil
guck mal das gibt doch schon wieder hier
nichts
das sieht ja aus wie aus dem sandkasten
gerade aber dann nicht so lange rühren
damit mehr weil sonst wird es fest uns
eben nicht so locker gegeben so sind zum
beispiel so skills die weiß ich nicht
gesagt und dann tritt doch stärker aus
oder wohnen ja also wenn man zu lange
rührt dann tritt dieses eiweiß dieses
klebereiweiß
[Musik]
wenn ich mal finster also es klingt hat
sonntags immer muffins backen dann sind
die mir ein bisschen zu trocken ich will
dass die so richtig saftig sachen dich
zu werden richtig deuce
okay die zutaten die erdnuss oder die
grob hacken oder um die habe weiß ich
was machen wir auch in der maschine das
machen wir in der
letzten reihe
hier
[Musik]
ein die hälfte
damit wird die hälfte noch so obendrauf
streckenlayout die hälfte
[Musik]
hiervon auch
das ist man so der trick finde ich dabei
und jetzt einfach kurz genau unterheben
weil die gekauften xxl muffins die sehen
ja immer so perfekt rapid aus und das
machen sie tatsächlich also obendrauf
noch mal streuen und dann überlässt man
es nicht dem zufall dass richter becker
ist ja geil
und jetzt praktisch immer zwei volle
portion ihrer vollen ein ständchen von
normalerweise nämlich einst für normale
muffins aber diese xxl teile die kriegen
uns war
[Musik]
die sehen super aus jetzt noch ein
bisschen drüber
jetzt noch von allen musst raus und habe
mir den arsch
und dann kannst du dir nämlich entweder
in den vorgeheizten backofen stecken bei
200 gerade wohnsitze oder zum beispiel
im backofen mit wachs sensor dann
erkennt der backofen schön wenn die
martins fertig sein dann
hat dann backofen ein bock seine sorgen
und dann holt er also dann holen wir uns
praktisch raus wenn der backofen sagt
jetzt sind sie perfekt man dann so eine
perfekte
man jetzt hier bei den x box sensor oder
wissenschaft dann auf kuchen auf
kleingebäck
fans
fertig jetzt müssen wir nicht mehr
darauf achten
gut ist
okay okay
für die marge bank cup cakes nehmen wir
250 gramm sonnenblumenöl etwa 200 gramm
butter milch vanille extrakt 200 compaq
mail oder mehl backpulver plus natron
150 gramm zucker etwas salz und
natürlich marzipan in der sorte sanddorn
also da bist du jetzt machen wir den
teig noch einmal
genau alle flüssigen zutaten alle
trockenen zutaten alles verrühren und
hier haben wir dieses schießen leo
die sind wie gemacht würde ich finde ich
die bahn die
richtige peggy march 5
genau da hast du direkten hand teurer
nun kann es auch die stäbchen benutzen
da muss ich für die veranschlagen und
ich werde dir ich würde die marke passen
wir die wiso kleine kügelchen rheinseite
hat man so jemanden finde ich gut
[Musik]
kommen leben wir mit nach vorne die sind
ja so schön
es muss hier ganz ehrlich sagen ich
glaube ich habe vorhin bei den zutaten
irgendwas falsch gemessen da war einfach
ein paar lampen aber dann gemerkt die
haben ein paar mehr gemacht aber jetzt
können wir die wieder rein portionieren
und ich nehme jetzt einfach diese marke
kann masse und teils in zwölf teile
[Musik]
aber bisher so dass muffins backen weil
es nicht schwer also es ist ja im
vergleich zum letzten mal da diese
klumpen die wieder gebacken haben ist
das ja heute ein spaziergang oder
[Applaus]
kommt aus berlin von einem freund von
uns wenden liebe grüße am 2 liebe grüße
alle spenden ich hätte gerne palette von
allen geschmacksrichtungen dass wenn es
da mata hat die besten mandeln das beste
man will muss mandelöl marzipan ok dazu
viele geschmacksrichtungen und er hat
und jetzt halte ich fest ein alpaka form
ist es so ja wir müssen uns wenn mal
besuchen ich war doch schon mit den
kindern ja sollen wir ja und da keine
anderen machen die jungen da kann sich
ja mal meine adresse und gebacken die
den vorgeheizten ofen und dann freue
mich kurz auf nikolov sie kurz ausruhen
und dann gibt's gleich die creme
[Musik]
ja das immer wieder unsere muffins sind
gebacken sehen toll aus die cupcakes
sind ausgebacken alles schön abgekühlt
und jetzt gibt es die creme und da hast
du die gewünschte tonka herz strom könne
als ich es gedacht mach' mal verspielte
seiner das ist so finde ich immer immer
lecker dafür nehmen wir für 100 gramm
frischkäse 80 gramm puderzucker 400
gramm sahne etwas tanker passte und
seiner partnerstadt schlagen dann darfst
du gerne frischkäse und puderzucker dar
eingeben und schon mal verrühren und
wichtig ist gleich wichtig dass die
muffins einfach schon mal schön kalt
sind was ich süß finde jetzt den
marzipan kern nicht mehr siehst der ist
komplett eingebacken jetzt richtig eine
überraschung
[Applaus]
das gründerteam romy sagte er
jetzt macht da nicht lange um die macht
sehr voller pulle und
ich gucke jetzt dass ich hinterher
kommen hier
und jetzt
mache ich die schöne portion
[Applaus]
wo ist der unterschied zwischen dem
senat und dem sahnesteif sahnesteif ist
tatsächlich nur für sahne tag soweit ich
weiss und salat ist echt nur mehr stärke
zucker und damit kriegst du auch quark
joghurt ein vitales angelegt ist okay ja
und einfach pro 100 milliliter flüssige
masse also sahne quark frischkäse einen
teelöffel und dann ist immer perfekt
frisiert super aus
hierdurch würde ich sagen ich will den
spritzbeutel
danke bloß mit der deko willst du dir
noch art déco toppings aussuchen
ich habe auch noch ein paar glitzer flex
ich finde glitzer musste drauf gaga ist
auch leo papier ja
das kannst du ja eigentlich auch roja
und dann sagt sie kann nicht bei
ajax spritzbeutel hier voll machen
kannst du noch gut bedient ja ich sage
ich sag's euch was ihr wollt ich mache
euch auch eine spur zu
machen
super
richtig schöne creme geboten vor
hingegen noch ein bisschen mehr rein
jetzt macht ein bisschen platz wie in
dem bekannten
schön auf
damals konnten hier
vorsichtig ja
früher zu ausgebacken meine mutter magna
doch das ist schön
ich finde in einem haushalt muss
gebacken wird ja aber ich bin keine
kuchen machen vielleicht kommt daher
auge
ich hoffe dass er egal aber ich bin so
es braucht so leben in der küche ja
okay dann zeig mal was du drauf hast
[Applaus]
sehr schön
tatsächlich ist aber noch einfacher wenn
du in der mitte start ist
okay also wieso und dann ja dann
nochmal ruft ja ich dir einmal zeigen ja
gerne aber ich finde ja auch schon schön
also tatsächlich ein echter erstellen
aber wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr zum
beispiel in der mitte starten so
und dann so drin immer den sprit würde
weiter
dann kriegt so ein höheres türkische hin
da ist probieren wir jetzt mal ach guck
mir passt es mir aus der hand jetzt bin
ich erst wenn du einen twist fast so
drees andersrum ich hab schon gemerkt
ich trete immer so rechts rum und andere
linksrum
[Musik]
schön
ich habe jetzt extern bisschen mehr
creme gemacht dass wir uns hier austoben
können aber ich sehe schon mal hopp
bisher weniger zubereiten können ich
gebe euch das rezept dann einfach für
zwölf cupcakes an aber es kommt ja halt
auch darauf an wie groß die sahnehaube
sein soll das ist aber auch echt super
also die creme
von der konsistenz die ist echt schön
geworden
also ich will nicht mehr hören dass du
sagst ich kann nicht backen ich bin ja
hier am dekorieren
ach das würde den unterschied ja das ist
okay habe ich habe kein gefühl für
teigwaren zum ofen ist ja
nicht nervt dass man auch wenn ich alles
abwägen muss
also das zubereiten und dekorieren und
jeden achten dass es wieder das ok du
brauchst einfach jemanden der das macht
sonst wie hat hat er vorbeikommt er
bereitet hier ist die creme hisste teig
machen
und vielleicht ja schön leicht
das schmeckt man die kalorien nicht
sofort spürt man dass sie spritzt
challenge ging mir gut von der hand das
hat auch niemand was anderes erwartet ja
ja sag es fast leer ja ein bisschen
heben wir noch auf für was auch immer da
tanze gern da reinstellen ja und dann
zuhause fertig dekorieren wie du
möchtest es sind deine cupcakes
sag mal ein bitte ich glaube ich für so
ein bisschen davon machen
ein bisschen dürfen
die so
ist eine schöne farbe
ob diese auch richtig schön die knie
passen auch noch gut zu diesem leo ja
gewöhnt
manchmal gleich probieren
das sieht schön aus sie sagen so in dem
aber in der dose sieht es nicht so schön
wolltest du dich noch mal kalt stellen
normalerweise ja aber cupcakes sind
immer sobald sie gestützt sind ready to
be ready turin und
wenn er das transportieren möchte ist
wie masken bis dann am besten in so eine
kuhglocke
da ist eigentlich ganz gut
das programm entwickeln ich mache das
für cupcakes mister kaufen und auch
heute nutze ich wieder meine sendezeit
um darauf aufmerksam zu machen dass sie
die produkte bitte alle kaufen die
online weil wir im shop gerne auch bei
lidl nicht von der konkurrenz
danke
ja das ist meine pressesprecherin sie
darf das ja auch dass man aggressives
marketing ja ja micha ok du machst sehr
charmant also erkannt ja auch damals sei
ich habe den charme erfunden ja
natürlich lecker so über die man sagen
wollen wir auch hier unsere unsere
schönen muffins daher den teil den ich
verbrannt habt ihr natürlich weg
18 die nicht möglich hier kümmerte schön
anrichten
unsere gäste machen
und wir machten uns mal mit drauf so
kalt und dann präsentiert stolz unser
backwerk von heute oder du deinen bruder
möchte behaupten dass es im gegen im
gegensatz zum letzten mal eine
steigerung ist ja hallo
oder computers und ehrgeizig wohl noch
in torten ständer
und den ständer packen war auch noch
voll mit der sprit war es soweit die
dann aufteilen
wird wenn das so weitergeht dann machst
du einfach aufhalten food habe ich dann
beim letzten maschen angehören ich habe
ja eigenen kanal war wussten einfach
übernimmst
30 alles an mich und ich mache alles
nach ich baue auch die küche genauso
nach und dann bringe ich auch produkte
aus die man genauso nach
probieren
und dort starben okay ist so kartells
naja vor der kamera wie ist auch ohne
kamera mache einfach so rein weißen
danach aussehen ließ okay nicht nehmen
läuft
dann nehme ich aus meinem sohn die
lippenstifte
der nazis
so lecker ich könnte mir so den beutel
in dem montagewerk in aussagen vom
fernseher bleiben wir abends einfach
schön prall spur zu halten
mit cupcake doping und den look sich
dann aus oder ich hängen diese an die
decke man kann nicht
meckern
das ist so gemein
wow
santon marzipan und tonka creme
ja ich hab halt ein auge dafür das
richtige auge führen für gebäck gepäck
sommer dieses mal probieren
[Musik]
ich mag immer wenn sachen nicht so süß
sind
weißt du was hier noch hätte
reingekommen ich war ein bisschen
zitronen oma hat das gerne möchte gerne
so dass
uns einen teil der mittel berichtet
jetzt
was lecker vom
schnittigen
schön mit notebook und diesen gesalzen
[Musik]
weißt du was hier noch reinkommt auch im
herren in der mitte noch richtig schön
was reinkommt meiste was man da machen
kann
so ein karamellbonbons ja die spritze
was drauf sondern karamellbonbons und
dann sagt man wie beim sneakers auch so
einen flüssigen kern
nun besser auf gut
guck mal hier süße maus jetzt noch sind
die blicke möchte aber die kriegen drauf
ich finde du solltest öfter zum backen
vorbeikommt darstellung neue kommen wenn
das einmal finden mit zum deppen machen
du kannst demnächst kuchen steaks machen
und dann einfach so zum deppen machen
lecker also probierte nicolas rezepte
gerne aus habe ich gern gemacht europe
und auch sagen wenn ihr fragen habt zum
thema backen einfach immer mehr schicken
genau da habe ich die rezepte auf meinen
auf meiner abstellen ja ist okay ich
schreibe bei uns genau so geht alcoa
geht alles an dich und ja
lecker war perfekt also machen jetzt
auch viel spaß gemacht und wir werden
noch was richtig lustiges staaten das
seht ihr was im nächsten video aber es
wird richtig gut es wird richtig gut und
richtig lustig und sehr spontan skaliert
vielleicht macht's gut bis zum nächsten
mal
jetzt können wir die wir stellen uns
fotos hat dann kannst du sagen wie du
die fotos haben willst ach so ja klar
hier gerne machen doch eine schöne
frische nicht mehr drauf
[Musik]
du machst ja diese asm er videos mit
fünf wie schon ja ja ich mache erst mal
videos
wachstums gab es ja mal mit einem buch
gemacht ja es war sehr erotisch wenn du
erst im august fast muss sich jetzt auch
ein bisschen konzentrieren bitten wenn
du erstmal videos märz musst du ganz
ruhig und
ruhigen und leidenschaftlich reden und
wichtig ist viele leute lieben es und
schmerz geräusche das heißt du musst das
richtig im mund massieren was auf
ach
sowas wird man
am besten geht das mit viel kleben und
kann glaub ich nicht schmerzen du musst
das massieren am tisch heißt es gestern
einmal gemacht er klebt sie haben
gegessen und dann hast du mir einmal so
richtige erstmal ob es geschickt und
was habe ich getan
hast und die erste gespürt so
okay so gemacht versehentlich und ich
muss direkt
mal hallo
das beschreiben was du tust
wahrscheinlich sehr
lecker
gibt es hier
und durch
durch bastian
jetzt hier
[Gelächter]
ja
ich würde sagen mitteilung ist auf ich
mache weiterhin kochen back videos und
du machst die
müssen aber eigentlich mal einen bug
video nur ja ja
ja ich kann
[Musik]